-My next guest stars in
the incredibly popular
television series "WandaVision."
The ninth and final episode of
Season 1 will be available
this Friday on Disney+.
Here is Elizabeth Olsen!
Ah! That's what
I'm talking about.
Welcome, Elizabeth Olsen.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm happy to see you.
Thank you so much, by the way,
for making the time to do
the "FallonVision" bit,
because it was awesome.
-That was so fun.
-It's so much fun for us.
But you -- I mean,
you went above and beyond
what we thought you would do.
And, actually, we were
sending you wigs and stuff,
and because of COVID
and where you are,
it couldn't get there in time.
So you went straight to
the top and had some
"WandaVision" people
help you with it, right?
-Yeah, 'cause I'm filming
"Doctor Strange"
right now with
the women who were
the head of hair and makeup
departments on "WandaVision."
And, so, we were doing
six-day weeks here in London
and we took our Sunday
to film it.
And I didn't have
anything for the '70s,
'cause there are no --
This is closed down.
Everything's closed down.
Shops are closed down.
You can't even
go to a thrift shop.
And I had a bad idea
for the '70s,
and they thought I looked
not good enough.
But they looked at
my dish towel in my kitchen
and they were like,
"That's your tube top.
You got to wear that
for the '70s."
I'm wearing a dishrag.
-I mean,
I did the scene with you,
but I didn't realize that was
not a dress or tube top.
That was a dishrag?
A dish towel?
-Yeah, it's a dishrag.
And it just got underneath
my armpits.
Like, in the back --
-We were this close.
-Like, it doesn't even remotely
come together in the back.
-So you're like this, like...
-I was.
And I was so scared
to lift my arms,
that the whole thing
would come down.
-Oh, my gosh! You got me!
See?
That's what you have to do
in these times.
You got to be nimble.
You got to be quick.
-Yeah.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you again for doing that.
It was a real treat
for all of us here.
And, also, Kathryn Hahn
was awesome, as well,
for helping us out.
I know you're in England.
You're filming
the "Doctor Strange" sequel.
Can we say anything that --
Does "WandaVision"
have a connection to
the "Doctor Strange" sequel?
-It is a complete tee-up
for my character.
-There you go.
I want to talk about
"WandaVision,"
'cause this is the biggest show
on television right now.
Congrats with all the success.
Did you expect the show
to be such a big hit?
-No. I expect everything
I do to fail.
-Aha!
-And I just try and hold on to
what I like about my job.
And I just assume no one
is going to
enjoy anything I'm a part of.
But we were really
swinging for the fences
and felt really proud of
what we were doing.
And we felt like
it was different and unique
and there was
a great energy to it.
But it --
You never know how something
is going to be received.
And we also didn't predict that
there was going to be
a pandemic, where everyone is
going to be living in a bubble,
like our characters.
And so it just kind of --
I feel like it was --
It came out at the right time.
And it really was
a labor of love,
so I'm really proud of it.
-I loved it.
I thought it was so good.
There's only one episode left.
Episode 9 comes out this Friday.
I'm assuming there's going to be
some closure to something or...
-I think so.
I think there is --
I think it answers
the rest of the questions
that people might have
and leaves things open
the way Marvel needs to
to link everything back
into the films.
And it's a Marvel finale.
-After every episode
of "WandaVision,"
fans head straight to Twitter.
I just thought I'd
run through a few tweets
and just see what your reaction
to some of them,
just in case
you didn't see them.
-Okay. I don't.
-This first one...
[ Both laugh ]
[ Cries ]
That is --
-That's like my first still.
I think that's my
first movie still, like, ever.
Like, was at Sundance.
-That's good. It's you.
It's acting. It's great.
Oh, alright. This one I like.
It says...
It's like, Wait.
How are you doing all these
bending around
and bending backwards,
and, at 18, this person's back
is already killing them?
-I mean, I don't remember
bending like that.
That isn't anatomically
correct to my body.
-No. That's something
that you've done --
Since the first time we saw you,
you've been doing these things.
And I go -- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean,
you might be on wires,
but you did it.
It's like --
-It's crazy-looking.
-Here's one that says...
It's like, "Wait.
Let me process.
Like, Huh? Wha-wha-what?"
-My mom just told me
the other day
that she's been calling me
the Red Witch for the last --
she said four years, but I think
I've been doing this
for like six or seven.
And she just learned that
I was called
the Scarlet Witch last week.
-She's like,
"She plays Red Witch."
-Yeah.
And she was like, "Why didn't
you ever correct me?"
And I just told her, "Because I
didn't know you were --
I just thought
you were making a joke."
I was like, "I didn't know
that's what you thought
my name was."
-"I love you too much, Mom."
And that's what moms do.
I'm not going to correct you
at every single thing.
Sure.
My dad still thinks
I'm Jimmy Kimmel.
-Right.
-I'm not going to -- Why am I
going to correct him now?
He loves him.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, this one made me laugh,
'cause I think it will
make you laugh, too.
It says, "Marvel writers --
'So, how much pain should
we put Wanda through on her
journey to become
the Scarlet Witch?'
Marvel -- 'Yes.'"
It's just not even an answer.
It's like, "Yes, more pain."
-Ultimate, ultimate sad girl.
-And this one, I just think --
Everyone liked this one.
It said, "Breaking news --
Elizabeth Olsen
is currently being
hospitalized due to carrying
the entire MCU on her back."
Yeah, that's your fans.
But that's the move!
That's the moves you're doing --
-That is the move.
I guess I do that a lot,
don't I?
-Yeah. You do it,
but everyone loves you.
And It's great.
Including us.
Congrats on all the success
with "WandaVision."
I want to show a clip.
Here is Elizabeth Olsen
in "WandaVision."
Take a look at this.
-Is she asleep?
-Mommy's not sleeping, honey.
She's just resting her eyes.
-Mom?
My head feels weird.
It's, like, really noisy.
I don't like it.
-Resting her eyes.
As punishment
for my reckless evening,
I plan on taking a
quarantine-style staycation,
a whole day just to myself.
That'll show me.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Oh, my God.
-Elizabeth Olsen, everybody.
Check out the season finale
of "WandaVision"
this Friday on Disney+.